[Music]
main review name review made with you
welcome everybody to meme review the
show where we will go through all of the
memes matter how important or trivial
the mean will be we will review it on my
new original show meme review first meme
which is my favorite it's the Ben's wall
mene it comes from kylo Ren in Star Wars
being topless for a few seconds in the
latest movie Star Wars Jedi which was by
the way if I may say so the greatest
Star Wars movie of all time
I love the humor I love the characters
but I especially loved this one scene
for five seconds where kylo Ren appears
with a high waist like my god how do you
how do you get it that tall FEM with
very tall waist and he's his man's man
sickles are ginormous
I remember watching this in his cinema I
turned over to Mars and I said my god
that man's breasts are gigantic I don't
know if I'm disgusting or if I'm turned
on and what was with the high waist
naturally when you see something weird
people people exaggerate it I like this
mean by the way what made you this way
there we have him with Lena Dunham
Dunham what doesn't matter look how
small you've become something far worse
has happened to you the protein shakes
where did you hide them
my god how did he get so slow kylo ren's
shirtless seen in the last Jedi was
weird but things really got out of hand
when Luke Skywalker squeezed one of his
four nipples and drank kylos on
pasteurized green milk what happened in
this movie what went wrong or should I
say went right my god this was the Death
Star
they sister [ __ ] star killer bait I
don't I don't understand this one to be
honest but it shows you that the man has
giant boobs she I bet you he has bigger
ones than her and it sort of makes you
understand the free the nipple movement
why can't I Lauren show his disgusting
men Stickles and women can't flaunt them
in public
hashtag free the nipples here we have
one of my favorite images and it really
captures the smallness of the Ben's wall
you don't want to see what's happening
here but can can I request an editor
making me into the bench small right now
the protein shakes where have you taken
them that's no moon it's been smoked
here we have of course the crossover
meme the monkey haircut you know we had
to do it to him
petting dog mean and reloading gun with
battery mean what the heck I don't sir
we're detecting a massive object
emerging from hyperspace it's been swell
everybody these high waisted pants are
to die for
and look we can add me into that meme
now that's a freshman boy I prefer the
real Supreme Leader I said the real
Supreme Leader perfection grandpappy
what is it grain see see it's not the
first time we've been blessed by nipples
in Star Wars but I do prefer Ben's woes
someone made a Ben's wall in in Dark
Souls
[Music]
of course you have to make all of them
this is how memes work these days you
know you gotta catch them all who would
win my heterosexuality one wide boy have
you bought my chair now this meme is
fresh it's it's it's universal
and it is servers I'm gonna rate this
meme a 4.9 unit yeah a 4.3
[Music]
[Applause]
next me on Twitter you may have seen
these type of tweets if you play bring
me to life by Evanescence at exactly
eleven 5908 on New Year's Eve the first
wake me up will play at exactly midnight
start off your New Year's right
this means started from a username a
blonde ocean which which pointed out
that if you start listening to nights by
Frank Ocean on December 31st at this
time the transitioning of the song will
sync perfectly within the next year so
let's say you're playing brotha brofist
song pewdiepie bro fist
[Music]
by 1911 56 the first bro faced will
start will be the first one of the year
start your year right now this is a
really good [ __ ] mean like the
Evanescence one is funny but if you play
stranger things theme thong and December
31st if you can live your 2018 like a
stranger things episode you're welcome
like I've got enough tentacles in my
life thank you very much if you play
star by Smash Mouth at exactly 11:15 9
the first hey now we'll start exactly at
midnight start to New Year's right
that's it that's funny
smash smash mouth is a funny meme
everybody
you don't play gucci gang by 11:58 you
will feel a lot better going into 2018
I'm gonna rate this mean a solid two and
a half because I don't like it okay I've
seen other people trying to make this
meme and you're not amusing me enough
for wanted to give it more than a two
and a half okay it's too much text okay
it's like I have to have to laugh
because I read all that text oh yes that
was mildly amusing next name place the
next meme is the probably one of the
bigger memes of December the Thai
political crisis breakup meme now I
didn't know it took me a long time to
find the original these meme apparently
it's a joke about having sex with a
woman that supports this Thai politician
I imagine it would be the same as going
home to a woman and find out she has a
picture of Hillary Clinton
and I don't know what the representation
is but at the same time
that's the joke you know I just noticed
there's a little weird guy in the
balcony
that's funny here we have another one of
battlefront two here we have the a JIT
PI one where [ __ ] his wife like he [ __ ]
our country here we have a JIT pi going
home with a woman sees the internet
disappears well the edits on this one is
creative and I will give points for that
I will not forget here here we have this
one where by cooks it's sort of a
reverse one cuz my cook is upset that
he's not getting cooked it took me a
long time to figure out but props to you
there we have a man that just decides to
recycle bottles and here we have Mimi
and Marcia look at that incoming call
original content I guess it's the same
one really these are two different memes
but they are sort of the same thing
reject your whamon because you have a
better call bonus meme we have time for
bonus meme everybody consider yourself
lucky
the chairman of the FCC I'm sure you've
seen this god-awful video where he you
know in my previous video I don't want
to take credit okay but in my video
about an anti neutrality I told I told
JIT I was like a JIT I don't understand
what the point of retracting net
neutrality is you need to do a better
job at explaining it to people so people
understand that's what I said and then
all the sudden he makes all the sudden
huh hey AJ I know you're watching this
you [ __ ] weird [ __ ] nerd bottom
think but you're not gonna be able to
watch me more edge it if you ruining
your trial with it well a JIT decided
well I'm gonna make a BuzzFeed video
explaining why of reducing net
neutrality won't change anything
[Music]
hi I'm Ajit pie I'm the chairman of the
FCC recently there's been quite a bit of
conversation about my plan to restore
Internet freedom here are just a few of
the things you'll still be able to do on
the Internet
if you still drive news right into the
ground you can still ruin memes as if
the Harlem shake wasn't ruined already
but then he also had the the wonderful
bit where he's looking at Game of
Thrones and the devil horns just can't
have escaped him and people thought wow
we can meme this so people started
adding a JIT pie approving of different
things here we have a JIT pie approving
my best video on this channel drinking
piss for views we have a JIT pie
watching his favorite show it's a 911
meme everybody now that's pretty edgy we
have object pie watching a jetpack here
we have a JIT pie watching one of the
greatest song this year a JIT pie
reacting to Doki Doki mean I'm gonna
write
Meem a solid 3.9 it's almost a four but
to be honest I'm a bit tired of all this
net neutrality [ __ ] please just stop
thank you for watching another episode
of meme review last one-hit trending so
keep up the support check out my patreon
link in the bottom and there's always
mean review
Merry Christmas
[Music]